>>Derick: When you look at the
whole big picture as one big thing,
it's gonna be like, it looks
super scary, but you take it
like piece-by-piece,
you can get through it.
>>Derick: Having the same advisor for
four years, they get a relationship
with someone that's not just
a teacher, a real person.
Being able to be an important
part of their lives.
And you can see the maturity level that
they take, and you see them change.
You see the growth in them.
>>Derick: It's stressful, lot
of stuff going on, it happens.
But you got it girl, you
got it, you're smart!
>>Gary: Advisory is a
small group of students,
fifteen typically with an Advisor.
They stay with that advisor
for four years.
The Advisor speaks a lot on
the behalf of the student
to community members or internships.
The Advisor's in constant
communication with the parents.
Anything that happens with that
student, it's like it happens with you.
>>Alex: I'm doing poetry,
songwriting, a short story.
That's another thing
that I'm pretty iffy
about when it comes to these things.
>>Gary: So in that, just think
about what gives you the best
case scenario to be successful.
>>Alex: Advisory gives a chance to work
on all of our schoolwork from the day.
And our Advisor, he will sit down
with us and actually take the time
to work one-on-one with us and make
sure that we have what we need.
>>Laura: The most important
thing in ninth grade Advisory
from Day One is setting what
the culture will be like.
Teaching them how to manage their time,
their projects, due dates, syllabuses.
Reflecting, journaling,
we do that every day.
That happens at the very beginning,
so whatever I'm doing that I want them
to kind of take with them all four
years, it's something I model every day.
>>Laura: Don't forget your
Reflection's due Friday.
>>Student: Yeah, Mr. Brown was
just talking about that today.
>>Laura: He talked about that today?
>>Chae: Because of the relationships
that you build within the Advisory,
people feel comfortable saying, "Hey,
this is what you've done well in.
And these are some things
that you should work on,
because they will help you be better."
When a student can relate
and they know that you care,
that makes a big difference.
>>Laura: Just make sure you do
the tracking for these two weeks.
>>Laura: And if it were me,
I might pick somebody in here
who will hold you accountable,
and make sure that they check
in with you every Monday,
Wednesday and Friday.
>>Dexter: Advisory's important,
because you could have people
that will always help you.
People that'll always support you.
But if you fail, then there'll be there
to pick up the pieces, and help me.
>>Laura: Advisory is so fundamental
because as they move forward they see it
as a family, they see it
as people they can trust.
>>Gary: Everything good?
>>Zetty: Yeah, everything's fine.
>>Gary: Okay, mom's good?
>>Gary: Has anybody called home
and said, "Zetty is killing it.
Zetty is doing so much better?"
No. Okay, I need to do that.
>>Gary: We have a very open
and honest relationship.
And really, there's nothing off-limits,
and I like to take that approach,
because I know at the end of the
day that I know the real student.
>>Gary: Okay, y'all, let's get
it started, let's get it jumping.
>>Gary: Every first Friday,
we pick a menu,
and every person has a responsibility.
They bring in their food
and we eat together
and we hang together
and we laugh together.
>>Gary: Robert, the lasagna's good!
>>Robert: Thank you!
>>Gary: Did your mom make it?
>>Robert: I made it.
>>Gary: What?!
>>Gary: That's just my way of
bringing them all back to this space,
and refocusing our energy
and hitting home the idea
that we're a unit, and
we're moving forward.
>>Robert: We've grown so
close from freshman year.
And whenever we have a personal
issue, or school-related issue,
we talk together as a class, and we try
to help each other out all the time.
>>Gary: Make sure that you look at
your exhibition date and time and put
that in your phone and
tell your parents about it.
>>Damon: He has given me the foundation
to go out on my own and be able
to succeed in everyday life.
He's given me tools and wisdom
that nobody else has given me.
>>Derick: You don't really realize
the impact you have on students
until you really spend a lot
of time with them, you know,
and you see the growth in them.
>>Gary: And what about, how do you feel?
>>Zetty: I'm happier that
my grades are better.
>>Gary: I have this fulfillment
at the end of the line,
and you see this finished work, you
understand the growth that was achieved,
and they understand that, and that's
what makes the journey worth doing.
>>Gary: You feel like you've got it now?
>>Alex: Yes, I think.
>>Gary: Excellent!
>>Alex: Really?
[laughter]